bonjour bassem merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes en direct de tunis comment la
situation est là bas bonjour david avait
coûté la situation ici est la même
depuis plus de quinze jours à savoir une
tension assez palpable que ce soit dans
la rue et puis plus depuis hier dans le
parlement également hier c'était tard
dans la nuit que le vote de confiance et
passait un remaniement ministériel
proposé par le premier ministre mais
chichi avec des députés des ministres
par donc ils n'ont pas été tous validés
par le président de la république qui a
annoncé que certains d'entre eux jugés
corrompus et qui a reconnu qu'il n'avait
pas assez de femmes dans cette
composition du gouvernement
l'opposition est montée au fond elle a
dit que comme quoi ce choix de deux
nouveaux ministres étaient faits
influencé par le parti ennahda le parti
islamiste qui est pointé du doigt par
les tunisiens c'est tunisiens qui se
sentent de plus en plus dans la rue une
nouvelle manifestation en ciel a été
organisé une manifestation d'ampleur
pour la capitale plus d'un millier de
tunisiens étaient réunis aux abords du
parlement je vous propose d'écouter
quelques unes de ses réactions
je suis venu ici pour réclamer les
libertés les droits et la justice
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour que tout
le monde soit ensemble
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui parce qu'en
tant que jeune cet état a dépensé pour
m'éduquer comme mes parents l'ont fait
pour que je réclame et droit je suis
venu en soutien mes camarades il y à la
société civile présente et nous sommes
ici en soutien de nos camarades
interpellés
libérés les interpeller c'est notre
principal slogan aujourd'hui et j'ai
tension elle existe depuis le 14 janvier
dernier le premier jour de confinement
généralisée en tunisie un jour qui a été
choisi non pas par hasard car c'était
l'anniversaire de la révolution de
jasmin révolution et un anniversaire
dont les tunisiens ont été privés c'est
ce qui a mis du feu de l'huile sur le
feu et qui a fait naître ces
manifestations et surtout beaucoup de
violences nocturnes dans les quartiers
populaires ainsi que dans plusieurs
villes de la tunisie entre jeunes et
forces de l'ordre beaucoup
d'arrestations beaucoup d'eux
me gardant la manifestation réclamer la
liberté la libération de ces jeunes qui
ont été arrêtés certains députés y
retard dans la nuit ont même annoncé
qu'ils pourraient rejoindre les
manifestants dans la rue pour qu'un
nouveau paysage politique se dessiner
que la tunisie puisse sortir de cette
crise politique sanitaire et puis
économique dans lesquels elle se trouve
depuis très longtemps mais ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui c'est que des
manifestations sont encore à prévoir
aujourd'hui demain dans les jours à
venir que ce soit à tunis ou dans le
reste de la tunisie merci beaucoup
bassam cheville en direct de tunis pour
toutes ces précisions